-You're on the cover
of "New York" magazine.
-Today.
-And there go, today.
-Look at that.
-Today.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's a fantastic photo shoot.
There is one photo I want
to show, because I've heard
you say that this was a --
This was difficult.
-This was one of
the hardest positions
I've had to be in
for a photo shoot.
-And I will say,
looking at it, you realize,
oh, you look very relaxed,
but that does...
[ Laughter ]
I -- I don't know
if I would be comfortable
in that position.
And also, no one would want
to see the resulting photos.
[ Laughter ]
-You never know, you never know.
-Yeah, you never know.
That's true.
-So I like, first of all,
that this looks like lips.
It's really cute, right?
-Yeah.
-But my knees were probably,
like, this far
from my shoulders, and
I was bending all the way down.
Kind of like
these steps right here.
And I had to push my neck up
and I was like --
And I was trying to model.
[ Light laughter ]
It was very difficult.
-How many -- How many shots
do you think it took?
-It took 30 minutes.
-30 minutes?
-30 minutes for the one shot
so -- It was worth it.
-But you've been working
your whole life for this.
-I have.
-Because you've been
doing modeling a long time.
We have some early photos,
because it's not all --
It's not all glamorous
butt in the air photos.
-No, no.
It doesn't start there.
So, this is actually --
What was this in?
-Okay, so this was in "SkyMall."
-"SkyMall," so there you go.
-So, any of your airlines.
You just pick up the magazine,
and you would see the "before."
-Yeah.
-And the "after."
-And it's -- I guess in
the beginning modeling days,
you start as a "before,"
and there you go.
"Before...
[ Laughter ]
Frizzy and curly."
-Frizzy and curly.
-Did they at least let you
also be the "after"?
I was, but they just popped
a wig on me, though.
-Oh, no.
-So, I knew, like, the --
The product
probably didn't work.
I am starting to think I'm going
to stop trusting "SkyMall."
-Yeah, right.
But you know what?
That's 17 years in the making,
and look at me now.
-Yeah, look at you now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How -- How far back does --
This is J. Lo's fashion line.
-J. Lo!
So, this is when J. Lo had
her first line out with Macy's.
I think I was about
14 or 15 years old here.
-There you go.
-And I share many of
these photos in my book,
"A New Model,"
because it's really fun
to go back and see
where you've come from.
-Yeah, of course.
And one of the things,
where you came from
and what you've sort of grown
into, is not only a model,
but you sort of described
yourself as a body activist.
-Yes.
-Tell us what brought you to,
like, giving yourself that title
or using that term
and where you are today on it.
-Well, social media plays
a huge role in everything
that I do, and I was just
posting normal photos of myself,
not retouching cellulite,
not retouching back fat,
and girls were saying, "Oh,
I have a body just like yours!"
And I realized that I had
a voice, and I had a reason
for women to say, "Oh,
I don't have to compare myself
to the skinny, regular girls
that media portrays
as perfect all of the time."
So I was, like, you know what?
I'm a body activist.
-Well, there you go.
-And so now,
I talk to young women.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I talk to young women,
older women,
but one of the best stories
that just happened to me
recently was a man e-mailed me
and said, "Thank you,
I'm finally having sex with
my wife with the lights on.
She feels sexy in the lingerie
that you created for her."
'Cause I also have
a lingerie line.
And it's like, "Yes!"
-Great.
-Because women should feel sexy
in bed, too.
-That's great.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. You can wear some
lingerie, too, Seth.
-I know.
I'm just thinking about it.
Lights on.
I feel like the reason
the lights are off is 'cause
my wife's not into my body.
[ Laughter ]
So, but you mentioned
this lingerie line,
and now I know that you actually
-- Now you're on the other side
of the casting table.
-Yes.
-And so, now you're finding
the models for your line.
-Yes.
-Is it more relaxing
to do it that way?
-Well, just today I had
a casting for my runway show
that's happening during
New York Fashion Week,
and it was bringing back all
these crazy memories...
-Sure.
...of showing up to a casting.
There we are, behind a desk,
just waiting for you to fall
and trip on your face.
But I was, like,
"No, girl, its okay.
Just come on in.
I know it's raining outside.
You look beautiful."
[ Laughter ]
And I really had to --
I want to book all of them.
They're so pretty,
but you can't.
-It's very helpful,
once you've been on one side.
-Yes.
-I think it makes you very...
certainly a lot more sympathetic
being on the other side.
-And then, I make them take
their clothes off,
put on my lingerie,
and then we have a party.
-Well there you go.
That sounds great.
You also have
"The Ashley Graham Show."
What is it called? Sorry.
-"The Ashley Graham Project."
-There you go.
-It's on Verizon go90.
-And your husband directed it.
-My husband directed it
and shot it.
I know, he's such a sweetie.
-Was he a good director?
Did you enjoy working with him?
-I mean, I love
working with him.
-That's great.
-Yeah, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Not only...
-And the whole film is shot
with the lights on,
which is great.
[ Laughter ]
That's a good sign.
Congratulations on everything.
-We do like the lights on.
-All right. Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you, Seth.
-Congrats on the book,
the show, the line.
-Thank you.
-Ashley Graham, everybody.
"Ashley Graham Project"
is available on go90.com
and through the go90 app.